merci Olivier Pacaud de nous accompagner
pendant la première demi-heure bonjour
vous êtes élu de l'Oise vous êtes
rattachés au groupe les républicains et
évidemment l'actualité ce sont ces
tensions qui ont émaillées plusieurs
villes de France cette nuit pour la
troisième nuit consécutive après la mort
du jeune Naël à Nanterre est-ce que vous
êtes inquiète de cette colère qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui dans tout le pays
évidemment la violence étant plus montée
d'un cran puisque
si les deux premières nuits semblaient
exprimer une colère aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on est passé à autre chose parce que
quand on voit des scènes de pillage de
vandalisme
l'émotion suscité par la mort d'un jeune
homme me semble bien loin je pense que
même si elle a pu être l'élément
déclencheur aujourd'hui les scènes de
pillage que l'on voit sont d'une autre
nature c'est l'étincelle mais pour vous
c'est plus la cause d'aujourd'hui la
mort de ce jeune el oui
oui franchement je pense que là on a
franchi un cran et aller piller des
magasins un peu partout en France
effectivement
des montres que la situation est
gravissime gravissime ça veut dire
qu'elle est révélatrice de quoi pour
vous cette colère on n'est pas
simplement dans une fracture entre la
police et la jeunesse on est dans autre
chose
oui on est probablement dans autre chose
le pays se porte très mal alors il se
porte très mal effectivement dans les
banlieues dans les quartiers sensibles
mais pas seulement il y a pour une
partie de ces jeunes qui vont
effectivement payer ces magasins
détruire de façon totalement gratuite
des bâtiments publics comme des
bibliothèques il y a la volonté
effectivement d'exprimer un malaise une
haine le fait peut-être de sentir qu'il
y a pas d'avenir entre guillemets pour
eux et je crois que c'est le plus triste
et puis il y a aussi le fait que on fait
de moins en moins de nations fait de
moins en moins de société ce pays il se
délite le lien social est plus que
distendu et je crois que même si notre
pays est confronté à très nombreux
problèmes écologiques démographique etc
la première des nécessités aujourd'hui
pour le gouvernement c'est vraiment de
dans l'immédiat c'est très difficile
mais il faut apaiser évidemment alors
l'apaisement est-ce qu'il peut passer
par des mesures symboliques peut-être il
passe par des discours
ce matin qui va se tenir à Matignon avec
une très grande partie du gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous attendez comme mesure
alors on va vous parler de l'état
d'urgence est-ce que c'est la mesure je
ne sais pas
le couvre-feu
en 2005 il a été instauré mais au bout
d'une dizaine de jours peut-être que
c'était trop tard je honnêtement je ne
sais pas il faut peut-être voir déjà ce
qui s'est passé cette nuit et là où il y
avait des couvre-feu parce que certaines
municipalités avaient instauré
découvre-feu est-ce que cela a été
efficace déjà donc on tienne dans votre
département
s'est passé la nuit à Compiègne je n'ai
pas de retour sur cette nuit là mais la
nuit précédente il y avait eu quelques
échauffourées des voyous avait tenté des
voyous il faut utiliser le mot mais
voyou avait tenté de s'en prendre au
commissariat et le maire de Compiègne
sénateur honoraire Philippe Marini avait
décidé à mon avis a juste titre
d'instaurer le couvre-feu cela a-t-il
été efficace honnêtement je peux pas
vous le dire à cette heure
mais donc il faut un couvre-feu dans les
villes où il y a des violences mais pas
un état d'urgence décrété par le
gouvernement c'est un dernier recours
c'est un dernier recours parce que
l'état d'urgence concerne toute la
population toute la France donc il faut
être particulièrement les libertés
publiques on y tient tous mais
effectivement lorsque la sécurité
publique qui est la première des
missions d'un État ne l'oublions jamais
est en jeu et bien il faut savoir
prendre les mesures le policier auteur
présumé du tir mortel a été mis en
examen pour homicide volontaire
volontaire et placer en détention
provisoire c'est une décision rare qu'en
pensez-vous il faut évidemment que
justice se fasse mais d'abord que la
lumière se fasse alors on a vu des
images
mais ces images ne permettent pas
d'avoir une compréhension totale des
faits
et donc c'est l'heure de l'enquête alors
visiblement les choses avancent assez
vite même si on entend quelques propos
contradictoires j'ai comme vous
certainement entendu l'avocat du
policier les avocats de la famille du
jeune qui a été tué il faut vraiment
aller jusqu'au bout
un policier ne tue ou ne tire jamais
sans y avoir été contraint
c'est un drame absolu mais je me
garderai bien de jeter la pierre
aux policiers
il faut pas généraliser non alors il y a
eu un geste très malheureux avec des
conséquences dramatiques mais on peut
pas amalgamer ce geste avec le travail
tout à fait remarquable et indispensable
de la police de notre République tient
d'abord parce qu'elle est soutenue entre
guillemets sécurisé par la police est-ce
qu'il faut revoir la loi sur les règles
d'usage des armes Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit
c'est un permis de tuer
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un cracheur de
feu et ses propos haineux non je ne les
partage pas du tout par contre et là
tous les syndicats de policiers sont
unanimes il y a probablement une
insuffisance de formation de la pour les
policiers et pour leur maniement de
l'arme ça c'est clair maintenant est-ce
que la loi doit être réformée je n'en
suis pas persuadé non
on constate une multiplication des refus
d'obtempérer est-ce qu'il faut durcir
les peines pour les auteurs de ces
refuses obtempérer probablement alors
effectivement c'est un symptôme
justement de cette délices et de ce
refus d'autorité que l'on que l'on
trouve un peu partout en France on va le
trouver effectivement face à des gens
qui donc refusent de s'arrêter lorsque
les policiers leur ordonnent mais aussi
lorsque des enseignants veulent
effectivement contraindre certains de
leurs élèves ou même lorsque des élus
veulent faire respecter certaines règles
dans leur commune c'est une
problématique générale alors il faut
certainement être plus sévère de toute
façon notre pays il souffre depuis des
années des décennies d'un laxisme
généralisé et on voit où ça mène
on va parler d'autres types de violences
les violences envers les élus puisque
c'est l'un poursuit son travail après la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin et
mercredi c'était la gendarmerie qui
était auditionnée Samia de chair a suivi
ses auditions elle vient nous en parler
[Musique]
bonjour Samia bonjour Oriane et Samia
vous avez suivi cette semaine l'audition
de colonel de la gendarmerie sur la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin oui
car les sénateurs veulent faire la
lumière sur les conditions qui ont mené
Yannick Morez maire de Saint-Brévin a
démissionné pour rappel il a jeté
l'éponge le 9 mai dernier après
l'incendie de son domicile depuis
plusieurs mois il recevait menace et un
jour de la part d'opposants à un centre
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile dans
sa commune il a publiquement regretté
d'avoir été je cite abandonné par l'État
alors qu'il avait écrit au préfet pour
l'informer des menaces qu'il recevaient
est-ce que la gendarmerie a reconnu des
défaillances non plutôt une
incompréhension et des regrets le
commandant de la gendarmerie des Pays de
la Loire là où se trouve la commune de
Saint-Brévin et d'abord revenu en détail
sur toutes les actions que les gendarmes
locaux ont mis en place avant l'incendie
ils ont organisé des réunions en mairie
et puis aussi des patrouilles autour du
futur centre d'accueil et de l'école
mais ils n'ont reçu aucune un style du
maire avant l'incendie effectivement
Yannick Morez n'a porté plainte qu'au
mois de mai bien après l'incendie de son
domicile qui a eu lieu le 22 mars alors
pourquoi n'est-il pas porté plainte et
bien il dit qu'il en aurait été dissuadé
par les gendarmes mais d'après les
gendarmes c'est un malentendu le 10
février une réunion a été organisée à la
mairie en présence du maire et du
sous-préfet je vous propose de regarder
un extrait du récit qu'on fait le
commandant de la gendarmerie des Pays de
la Loire
alors que le maire a conclu qu'on le
dissuadait de déposer plainte au motif
justement de la liberté d'expression le
commandant de compagnie lui listé de son
côté
les les infractions en indiquant que
pour être poursuivi elles doivent être
caractérisés au sens du code de
procédure pénale alors il m'aime pas
évident il me paraît évident que ce
message n'est pas bien passé
car certainement trop technique
par rapport à une victime qui se sentait
démunie isolée et on attend surtout de
réponses de réponse immédiate pour être
rassurée
c'est naturellement c'est naturellement
regret finalement ce qui semble
ressortir de cette audition c'est
surtout la question de la relation entre
les gendarmes et les élus qui
visiblement ici a été défaillante mais
qui si on en croit les sénateurs les
témoignages et différents sénateurs au
cours de l'audition sont plutôt bien se
passer à peu près partout ailleurs sur
le territoire est-ce que vous diriez que
vous dans votre commune les gendarmes
sont suffisamment accompagnent
suffisamment les élus face aux menaces
aux violences dont ils peuvent être
l'objet dans mon département de l'Oise
oui la plupart du temps lorsqu'il y a
des problématiques qui donc touchent les
élus des problématiques de sécurité ils
sont bien soutenus par les gendarmes je
vais vous donner un exemple que j'ai
vécu la semaine dernière c'est le maire
d'une commune qui s'appelle Catillon
Fumechon il a reçu des de mort par sms
il est allé à la gendarmerie sa plainte
a été prise immédiatement depuis aucune
nouvelle de la justice mais les
gendarmes ont fait leur question qui a
été soulevée dans l'audition par les
sénateurs est-ce que le problème ne
vient pas justement plutôt du côté de la
justice que des gendarmes parce que
visiblement il y a beaucoup de mères qui
portent pleines et les procureurs qui ne
donnent pas suite dans de nombreux cas
mais pour moi c'était évident en tout
cas les cas que je connais dans mon
département les gendarmes ont fait leur
travail la justice a jugé
inutile de poursuivre les investigations
et j'ai plusieurs exemples
malheureusement en tête de plainte qui
avait été déposées pour pour défaites
très concrets des menaces très concrètes
et aucune suite n'a été donnée aucune
suite n'a été donné par le procureur les
procureurs puisqu'il y en a plusieurs
dans le département on a entendu un
chiffre en cours de 7 audition entre
2021 et 2022 les plaintes pour violence
envers les élus ont augmenté de 32% ,
est-ce que c'est le cas aussi dans votre
département dans les communes de l'Oise
est-ce que vous avez vu le nombre de cas
augmenter
j'ai pas de chiffres précis mais
effectivement lorsque vous allez sur le
terrain et j'y suis quasi
quotidiennement et que vous avez des
témoignages effectivement on me parle
plus aujourd'hui de problèmes
relationnels qui peuvent effectivement
déraper avec donc des administrés qu'il
y a 5 ans par exemple j'ai pas de
chiffres à vous donner mais
effectivement la situation ne cesse de
se dégrader on respecte de moins en
moins les charpente entre guillemets
parce que 32% en Samira playtif c'est un
chiffre qui est énorme comment on
enraille ce phénomène tolérance zéro
déjà c'est la première des choses
tolérance zéro il faut rien laisser
passer et après effectivement il y a
l'éducation qui a son rôle clé à jouer
mais il y a aussi le rôle des parents on
n'a jamais prononcé ce mot aujourd'hui
mais les parents doivent éduquer leurs
gamins et à 11 ans à 12 ans à 15 ans on
n'est pas dans la rue
à 9 heures du soir ou à minuit non donc
notre société elle est malade alors
c'est globale et je crois aussi que la
parentalité doit être repensée entre
guillemets ou en tous les cas on doit
revenir à des fondamentaux de base
vous disiez pas par rapport à la justice
le gouvernement a fait des annonces
après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin et notamment renforcement
des sanctions pénales pour les auteurs
de violence envers les élus alignés sur
les auteurs de violence envers les
forces de l'ordre est-ce que c'est la
bonne réponse si comme vous le dites de
toute façon les peines ne sont pas
appliquées est-ce qu'il faut renforcer
encore ces sanctions je ne sais pas s'il
faut renforcer ces sanctions je pense
que
je pense que l'arsenal juridique existe
encore faut-il peut-être revenir à
l'idée de de peine plancher
d'automaticité dans certains cas
je pense sincèrement que pour tout ce
qui concerne des atteintes à l'intégrité
ou des menaces vis-à-vis de toute forme
d'autorité toute femme d'autorité
c'est-à-dire les élus mais aussi les
forces de l'ordre les enseignants les
pompiers effectivement faut peut-être
être un petit peu plus sévère et
reprendre des mesures qui existaient
jadis dans certains cas concernant la
parentalité dont vous parliez on sait
que les violences envers les élus elles
sont pas forcément le fait de jeunes au
contraire c'est souvent des adultes qui
sont des administrés alors est-ce que
vraiment c'est la Paris parentalité qui
est en cause dans le cas des violences
envers les élus c'est pas c'est pas
forcément effectivement la parentalité
qui est en cause mais ma réflexion
n'était plus globale
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire du coup
alors vis-à-vis des fauteurs de troupes
vous dit oui vis-à-vis des parents
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors il y
avait quelques mesures comme par exemple
toucher aux porte-monnaie pour les
allocations familiales malheureusement
ça marche toujours enfin malheureusement
non il faut pas avoir peur de prendre
des mesures sévères je me dis le laxisme
généralisé abouti à la chialie que l'on
constate aujourd'hui tolérance zéro pour
revenir aux violences envers les élus il
y a près de 1300 mères qui ont
démissionné depuis 2020 est-ce que pour
vous c'est un phénomène qui va
s'accentuer est-ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour les prochaines municipales de 2026
oui je pense
alors beaucoup de communes sans
candidats c'est possible et beaucoup de
communes où les listes seront
compliquées à monter et beaucoup de gens
oublient qu'en 2020 il y a eu beaucoup
moins de candidats déjà il y a une fonte
des glaces citoyennes il y a de moins en
moins de candidats pour effectivement
s'engager envers Marianne mais il y a de
moins en moins de bénévoles dans les
associations les gens se replient sur
eux-mêmes on ne fait de moins en moins
sociétés envie de moins en moins
ensemble envie de plus en plus côte à
côte c'est une cohabitation sociale
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et c'est
très triste et je pense que 2026 va être
inscritin assez dramatique une
démocratie locale en danger du coup dans
notre pays oui et il y a des petits
règles simples qu'on aurait pu mettre en
place moi j'avais déposé des amendements
lors de certains textes de loi pour
permettre par exemple que les les listes
soient pas forcément aussi nombreuses
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple dans une
commune de 500500 habitants vous avez
obligatoirement 15 conseillers
municipaux pourquoi pas 11 pourquoi pas
de 13
il faut savoir assouplir pour s'adapter
aux problématiques mais en même temps il
faut redonner envie de citoyenneté entre
guillemets et aujourd'hui il y a
tellement de contraintes administratives
il y a tellement aussi de problématiques
d'insécurité que beaucoup de gens
préfèrent jeter l'éponge et c'est très
triste pour notre pays merci Samia à
tout à l'heure merci Oriane on va parler
des violons urbaines et de l'état
d'urgence on va voir avec vous en quoi
ça consiste précisément à tout à l'heure
Samia merci beaucoup un mot sur la
décision du Conseil d'État hier Olivier
Paccot le Conseil d'État qui a maintenu
l'interdiction du port du hijab pour les
footballeuses il n'a pas suivi la vie du
rapporteur public ce qui est quand même
assez rare qu'on dit de vous ça je
décision pour le football c'est à dire
que jouer avec un hi jump un grand fan
de foot tu m'as persuadé que ce soit si
pratique que ça bon c'est une boutade
mais
ni Dieu ni à la ni Marx non leur place
sur un rectangle vert ils sont pas
inscrits sur la feuille de match et la
décision du Conseil d'État c'est une
décision marquée du coin du bon sens
laïque
le sport c'est un des derniers endroits
où la mixité sociale existe et donc si
on laisse s'y entrer ce germe de
communautarisme
et ben c'est dramatique donc c'est vrai
que j'avais été très surpris des propos
du rapporteur public que j'avais trouvé
totalement
inadapté à
la réalité des besoins de de cohésion
sociale et j'ai été très rassuré par la
décision du Conseil d'État oui on va
voir l'actualité dans nos régions avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va à Metz retrouver Alexandre
poplavski bonjour Alexandre merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef adjoint du Républicain
Lorrain on va d'abord parler avec vous
Alexandre de l'industrie automobile avec
un nouvel investissement pour stellantis
près du site historique de Sochaux
oui le site de bellechamps qui est situé
à quelques kilomètres du berceau
socialien de l'Aventure Peugeot et le
centre d'essai historique est toujours
de points de stylantis ce jeudi la
direction a confirmé un nouvel
investissement de plus de 6 millions
d'euros pour la construction d'un tout
nouveau banc d'essai dédié à
l'électrification selon le calendrier il
devrait rentrer en service d'ici la fin
2024 les tests se concentreront sur de
nouvelles générations de batteries dans
trois domaines spécifiques la
propagation thermique la résistance au
feu et les fuites internes pour prendre
la mesure de l'importance de ce centre
il n'y en aura que deux à l'échelle du
groupe au 14 marques qui effectueront
des essais similaires l'autre site
concerné se trouvant en Amérique du Nord
vous avez une question Alexandre pour le
sénateur bah oui c'est la preuve aussi
que nos nos grands groupes continuent à
investir dans des dans des technologies
de pointe dans nos territoires et ça ça
contribue à la réindustrialisation
également
on a besoin de réindustrialiser notre
pays
la tendance semble s'inverser et je m'en
félicite il y a une désindustrialisation
massive qui a touché tout le territoire
aujourd'hui il y a des nouvelles
usines qui ouvrent souvent avec un
nombre d'employés moins importants
qu'auparavant mais c'est dû aussi aux
évolutions technologiques mais il faut
réindustrialiser et pour cela
effectivement il faut attractice notre
territoire alors faire venir des
investisseurs étrangers c'est très bien
mais il faut aussi surtout susciter
favoriser encourager l'initiative locale
en créant un
microclimat économique favorable
justement à l'investissement je pense
que certaines mesures gouvernementales
vont dans le bon sens les chiffres sont
plutôt positifs mais quand on va
jusqu'au bout des analyses on voit que
lorsqu'il y a des investissements par
exemple au Royaume-Uni ou en Allemagne
ils sont parfois moins nombreux mais ils
sont plus créateurs d'emploi donc tout
n'est pas parfait mais moi je ne peux
que me féliciter de ces investissements
massifs qui ont lieu du côté de Sochaux
autre
plus festif Alexandre on va voir on va
parler avec vous des eurockennes de
belforts de Belfort elles ont connu des
déboires divers et variés ces dernières
années
[Musique]
deux éditions le festival franc-comtois
donc à lancer ce jeudi avec sur scène
niska a des Shaka Pons ou encore un
Skrillex quatre jours de fête qui
s'annoncent déjà comme un énorme succès
populaire dès l'entrée des premiers
festivaliers sur le cimetière la
tendance imaginer depuis quelques
semaines c'est confirmé entre 120 000 et
130 000 festivaliers sont attendus d'ici
dimanche soir sur le site du massocie
dans le Territoire de Belfort
vous avez une question pour Olivier
Pacaud
parce que oui c'est c'est la preuve que
c'est ces festivals
tels que Solidays qui a qui a vu venir
200 000 filles festivaliers ou encore ou
encore Hellfest
marche fonctionne et en plus ils savent
s'adapter au contexte
du réchauffement climatique avec
optimisation des déchets des circuits
d'achat responsables je voudrais avoir
un peu votre regard moi sur cet
engagement à la fois vert de ces
festivals et leur santé
écoutez la France c'est le pays des
festivals il y a beaucoup plus de
festivals notamment musicaux en France
que quand en Italie qu'en Allemagne ou
qu'au Royaume-Uni ce soir moi je vais
dans un petit festival dans l'Oise la
nuit des concerts de porquerricourt
demain je vais dans un autre festival
dans l'Oise qui festival qui s'appelle
barbe rock à Crèvecoeur-le-Grand ça fait
vivre nos territoires ça permet une
expression artistique particulièrement
riche alors oui c'est formidable il faut
les encourager la seule chose qui me
gêne un petit peu dans les grands
festivals
qui attire beaucoup de monde c'est que
les cachets qui sont demandés de la part
de certains groupes deviennent
totalement démentiels quand on voit vous
avez parlé d'alfest quand on voit que
Metallica j'aime ce qui fait du bruit
quand on voit que métallique à demander
à pour le précédent Hellfest 1 cachette
3 millions d'euros il y a des questions
à se poser voilà on va dans la démesure
et la problématique de ces festivals
quand même pour les spectateurs c'est
que le prix du ticket est quand même
assez élevé
je vais aller voir Depeche Mode il y a
une semaine au Stade de France était
formidable mais le prix du piticet le
prix du ticket moyen il est pas loin de
100 euros tout le monde peut pas se le
payer ça c'est un vrai problème pour là
où il y a des grands groupes alors
heureusement qu'il y a des petits
festivals avec des groupes moins connus
ou le prix d'entrée est beaucoup moins
cher parce qu'il faut que la culture
reste accessible à tous
et aujourd'hui pour ces grands groupes
il y a pas de culture populaire c'est
une culture qui du coup est assez
liquide vu le prix des places
moyen des gens qui sont dans ces
concerts ils grimpent les jeunes ne
peuvent pas y aller sauf s'ils ont des
parents fortunés
Alexandre une autre question où on
regarde la une
on regarde la Une de l'Est République du
coup pour les eurockennes Eurockéennes
la fête basse son plan c'est à la une ce
matin de l'Est Républicain bah déjà son
plan même merci beaucoup Alexandre pople
d'avoir été avec nous et bonneuroquet du
coup merci beaucoup Alexandre un dernier
mot sur les sénatoriales Olivier Pacaud
vous êtes candidat dans l'Oise il y a
trois candidats de droite il y a trois
sénateurs sortants de droit d'ailleurs
on va le regarder et vous partez sur
trois listes séparés pourquoi
alors mes deux concurrents
Rossignol malheureusement se fait couper
la tête elle a pris un parachute elle
arrive dans le Val de Marne
donc oui il y a trois sénateurs sortants
il y en a deux qui étaient sur la même
liste l'année dernière la dernière fois
Édouard et Jérôme Bachar c'est à eux
qu'il faut poser la question moi
personnellement je continue ma voix moi
malice s'appelle notre partie c'est
l'Oise elle n'est pas soutenue par un
parti politique et c'est une volonté
écouter pourquoi on est sur des listes
différentes d'abord parce que moi j'aime
la démocratie la démocratie c'est le
choix il y a eu trois trajectoires
différentes trois sénateurs qui ont fait
leur travail à leur façon qui ont été
sur le terrain ou dans l'hémicycle plus
ou moins fortement et bien ce seront les
grands électeurs qui jugeront et je n'ai
pas peur de du verdict populaire voilà
un mot un dernier mot juste parce qu'il
y a une poussée du rassemblement
national dans votre département est-ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir un sénateur ils ont
trois députés sur sept aujourd'hui donc
effectivement il y a une très forte
poussée qui existe cette depuis
longtemps quand même dans l'Oise mais
ils n'auront pas de sénateurs je suis
catégorique et ensuite évidemment cette
élection les sénatoriales je le rappelle
c'est le 24 septembre prochain merci
beaucoup merci Olivier Pacaud d'avoir
été avec nous dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on reparlera
évidemment de ces violences qui ont eu
lieu cette nuit pour la troisième nuit à
travers tout le pays analyse de ces
tensions avec le constitutionnalisme
Benjamin Morel et drissate Youssef
expert en sécurité on en parle tout de
suite avec notre prochaine invité c'est
l'avocat pénaliste Henri Leclerc qui
nous rejoint